hello from comic-con Hyrum it's the den
of tens of thousands of fanboys and geek
girls it's easy to start thinking that
nerd culture is the center of the
universe that's because it actually is
Hollywood is trying to tempt comic book
fans into the multiplexes to watch thor
and captain america networks are
applying them with fantasy and science
fiction theme shows and now even the
White House is getting in on the act
yesterday they sent out an announcement
titled we the geeks the stuff
superheroes are made of after
name-checking comic-con and showing a
pic of the Prez being attacked by Spidey
mmm he seems awfully young there that
must have been right after he was bitten
by a spider anyway the White House
announced that they're hosting a Google+
Hangout to get all geeky about people
inventing real-life invisibility cloaks
and liquid armor and Batman like
ascenders first of all this feels like
they're trying way too hard you aren't
the Marvel super villain rhino so stop
Horning in on our subculture secondly
are these amazing inventions in the
White House supposed to make me thrill
to the wonders of real life science
because all it's making me think of is
that a board Joe Biden could commandeer
all of these scientific super devices
and use them to strike fear into the
hearts of filibustering congressman you
don't like the NSA snooping around in
your phone records well just imagine a
vice president armed with the power of
invisibility remember Joe with great
power comes great responsibility